oh yes hi we are eating
hi I'm Yancey nice to meet you hi guys
I'm Ted young
hi I'm Newton hi I'm Yuma hi guys I'm
Lea we're here at BuzzFeed right now and
we're going to be playing a game of who
sue let's start
[Music]
she's very good dancer especially
memorizing it yeah sure your dad she's
so fast I mean definitely I would like
you to fund myself but sadly that's the
truth I really like sweet potato and
things like that so I write it in
airfryer you don't don't do that you
don't have to like take it from this
exact I go like - mmm - singing yeah
perfect place then go check out for me I
know pretty good at doing copying others
yes expressions yes just good at
catching it yes catching the point I was
on Yoona Chad I'm done enough okay okay
get me some you didn't do this yeah I
don't know I tell you potato nachos I
love my short day
it's really funny one because you know
how when you're taking a selfie
you have to like ah yes it's really
embarrassed
like she what he doesn't think about it
and she sees us it's like that awkward
moment that happens there don't be shy
she's very shy we actually caught like
edgy like search us up like it see up
not herself like it see up lots of the
time so yeah we don't talk about it ah
hell no it makes you laugh it's good
thing but she use I wanted us here no
thank you
it's my energy just you know have a good
yes I think yeah like the most funniest
remember in our time me he's the one who
I know that eating together onion I like
it
she has very many friends and she really
does texting on her family very much my
thoughts picture
[Music]
[Music]
he doesn't eat healthy food but she
tries to be healthy she knows lots of
restaurants that are really famous on
SMS or maybe that went on TV and stuff
because I don't know much but she you
know brings sometimes takes me to some
of the nice places
[Music]
[Applause]
the key word look randomly yeah I really
wanna cook I made her can't you sue oh
really
orders the new alright now I wrote and I
like ordering stuff we need two fingers
no I'm going crazy today because you
have to my room dude four five five zero
she's really into it so she's saying I
need to play almost I need to play or
like all the time no I really like to do
so we tear it makes inner peace
yeah thanks for watching us I must be
you hope you guys enjoyed the video this
was